qué apoyo pudo haber tenido
el ejército ruso
según The New York Times el general
sergeiking estaba al tanto del deseo del
líder de Wagner de organizar una
rebelión la prensa rusa lo apodaba como
general Armagedón y fue nombrado como
jefe de operaciones en Ucrania en
octubre de 2022 por el Ministerio de
defensa ruso Aunque posteriormente este
rol fue cedido a Valery y el General
armageddon quedó como su adjunto según
el periódico estadounidense otros
generales del ejército ruso pudieron
haber apoyado el plan del jefe de la
milicia paramilitar informaciones
calificadas de especulaciones por parte
del kremlin pero funcionarios
estadounidenses informados por servicios
de inteligencia están en búsqueda de
pistas para entender los hechos del 24
de junio el papel del ejército ruso es
uno de los puntos que las
investigaciones buscan
el líder del grupo Wagner probablemente
no habría intentado su marcha Moscú si
no hubiera pensado que tendría apoyo
allá sus tropas Podrían haber ido Por
esa carretera principal la M4 hacía
Moscú con poca resistencia quiero decir
con unos pocos disparos y solo unas
pocas muertes eso plantea la pregunta
unas horas antes de las revelaciones del
periódico estadounidense fue el
presidente bielorruso quien entregó
nueva información le dije a Putin
podemos matar a brin no hay problema si
no es en el primer intento será en el
segundo pero también le dije No hagas
eso Porque entonces no habrá negociación
Estos tipos saben cómo defenderse han
luchado en África Asia América Latina
están listos para todo nosotros también
podemos matarlos pero morirán miles de
civiles y todos aquellos que se oponen a
Wagner según Alexander en lucasenco el
jefe de Wagner llegó el 27 de junio a
Bielorrusia cumpliendo con el acuerdo
que puso fin a la Rebe